so where to even start
holy crap the editing the editing was
was shocking shockingly awful
um now not not quite not quite a Last
Airbender bad but on the way there um if
you've seen me talk about The Last
Airbender then then I've done a really
thorough rundown of a lot of the editing
problems with Last Airbender now the
thing with Last Airbender is it has both
like deep structural editing problems as
well as moment to moment editing
problems this one doesn't quite as get
as bad on the moment-to-moment there's
some really bad moments but mostly it's
like bigger structural story like just
overall flow like they took a three-hour
movie and tried to compress it into an
hour and a half so it just it goes the
the pace is so bad so bad and the flow
is so if you've seen Batman vs Superman
there's a sequence in there where Bruce
Wayne watches a bunch of YouTube videos
about Aquaman and Wonder Woman and the
flash and it's this sequence that's
really really mismatched between the
soundtrack like the soundtrack is trying
to get you like super amped up but the
visuals are like really low-key and
boring and like not much is actually
happening and that everything moves just
really like it takes a really long time
to communicate information that could be
just compressed far more efficiently
that that is basically the first like 20
minutes of this movie it's a really
really obnoxiously long montage and it's
very clear that at some point they
brought in an editing team a polishing
team to go over it and and just try to
amp it up a little bit because they've
they've put in all of these special
transitions you know with like just just
kind of things go kind of neon and
comic-book he edits it's really really
mismatched with with everything else and
it's clear that that was added later and
it's clear that the the soundtrack like
the heavy heavy use of pop music right
not just heavy use of pop music but
heavy and heavy-handed use of pop music
throughout this that was that's clearly
clearly an attempt to like salvage tone
at like the 11th hour there there is no
way that this was not shot and initially
cut or there there's no either this
wasn't shot and initially cut with the
same pace and tone and we'll probably
length as as Batman versus Superman like
this play is like it was originally a
very long movie that has been really
heavily compressed you've got you've got
some basic like conceptual flaws in
there like with the whole Suicide Squad
itself and like the composition of it
Killer Croc is fairly superfluous but at
least he's visually distinct Captain
Boomerang is an utter waste of space I
have no idea how he survived you know
and the number of like screen like
screenplay drafts that would have been
necessary to get this
get this through to the end like he
doesn't do anything meaningful
he doesn't contribute anything he's not
super-powered like so their basic like
premise of like oh we're going to get
we're going to get our own metahumans in
order to fight back like Captain
Boomerang is so redundant he's not
super-powered um he's he's not even
particularly good at anything that other
people aren't also good at like oh he's
kind of good with a boomerang but that
really he's just a thief who has a stick
um like he's got a gimmick that he uses
boomerangs that's it he's you know and
if he was a psycho well he's a really
good shot well Deadshot is like a
perfect shot so it's like why why is he
there and because of that he doesn't do
anything and he just kind of hangs out
in the background and occasionally makes
a not terribly funny snarky quip and he
might as well not be there there's they
okay so that first 20 minutes where
they're just kind of running through
this montage of like introducing all of
their characters without actually
introducing them one character like so
then then they bring everyone together
after that like a while after that for
really kind of not well clarified
reasons but they bring everyone together
and then out of nowhere they introduce a
new character not nearly as in as much
depth they introduce a slipknot and it's
literally like he steps off a helicopter
and they're like that slipknot he can
climb anything that's all the
introduction that he's given and like
seven minutes later he's dead
um because so they they take this to the
squad and they put bombs in their necks
and Slipknot is introduced right before
they go into their like combat zone
purely so that they can demonstrate to
the audience that there are indeed
actually bombs in their necks and they
will explode so he's he is killed to
prove a point
minutes after he's introduced it is it
is the most hack thing I have I have
seen in in a major motion picture in
years there's tons of stuff that they do
not do not adequately explained or set
up or really like get you invested in
except for one thing the one thing that
they consistently reinforce through the
entire movie is it's like okay so the
the main villain is enchantress um
because she's this ancient witch from
another dimension and she manages to
kind of like get free and what they were
using to control her was her heart it's
like oh well if you know if she's got
her heart she's got her full power and
if we've got her heart then we can
control her by basically using it as
leverage and like stabbing it if she
gets out of line and like you know we
could crush it and kill her or whatever
and so the whole stakes of like if
chanters has if enchantress has her
heart it's bad news and her heart is her
weak point this is this is told to the
audience it is shown to the audience it
is repeated to the audience it is
reinforced it is the stakes of the first
like like major peak is that it's like
oh she gets her heart back and that's
kind of the second act Gulch for for the
characters like that's their lowest
point when they're like oh crap all is
hopeless because she's got her heart
back and now she's full power and so you
get to the actual final climax and
there's like a bluff and Harley like
Harley hits it like you know cuts
enchantress and like pulls her heart out
and this is the one thing that you could
totally just just roll with it the
audience it is being clearly established
to the audience
what this means like what the stakes are
and what it means if the Enchantress's
heart is damaged and no joke so it's
like she cuts and then it goes to boring
mix soldier guy and he turns to Will
Smith and says her heart is damaged
that means she's weakened and we can
finally hurt her like yes this is this
hole he has an entire Jiri explains the
entire premise of Enchantress's heart to
a character to Deadshot
those are probably the two big moments
that that I've just spectacularly awful
or I should say easily compressed awful
is is Slipknot being introduced only to
be killed moments later and and boring
soldier guy re-explaining the stakes in
the middle of combat in like in in the
most ham-handed way possible and it and
again it's funny because of all the
things that the movie under explains or
just under cells this is the one thing
that they've actually very clearly
established it is the only thing that
they have super clearly and decisively
established about the rules of their
screenplay and and they were so insecure
in it that the editor decided to
re-explain it to the audience
there there's on the bigger structure I
guess here's a here's an example of sort
of some of the bigger bigger structural
problems is that so the whole set up
between the military and the Suicide
Squad you know for for whatever reason
they have decided to make this like
hyper antagonistic for the entire you
know first 40 minutes of the movie like
it is hyper antagonistic and and it's
brutal like it's really really dark and
and like emotionally violent in tone
like they show Harley being being
force-fed through a through a nasal tube
you know they they imply like a lot of
abuse and assault towards these
prisoners and it's it's really like it's
not it's it's not fun antagonistic like
oh we've got rapport like yeah you're
you're a prisoner and we just kind of
you know it's it's not glossed over it's
really really kind of playing like with
this abuse just to interrupt myself here
but I feel I need to further clarify
just how abusive the film is towards
Harley in specific in addition to the
forced feeding by a nasal tube Harley is
also subjected to repeated physical and
emotional abuse by Leto's Joker
including forced electroshock which is
played off with sexual undertones and
talking her into killing herself which
is also played off with sexual
undertones the montage of various
prisoner abuse includes multiple scenes
where early is framed in a submissive
position on the floor nearly naked while
multiple heavily armed men surround her
and laugh while this is seemingly
intended to play against her combat
prowess as a form of irony that irony is
entirely disarmed by the fact that she
is still their prisoner so she kills her
mames a garter - big deal they still
retain power over her so it's
established that kind of a relationship
in tone
and then it kind of has to try and
figure out how to spin that into them
cooperating but they they missed the
whole part where they actually like try
to good cop them like they they just
kind of completely skip it or just gloss
over it superfast where it's like oh
yeah we'll we'll knock time off your
sentence and the thing is is that all of
these people have been locked up
essentially indefinitely so it's like oh
we'll knock some time off of your like
triple life sentence and it's like
alright that's not meaningful the only
person the only character that they
actually establish any sort of like
leverage with is Deadshot in that it's
like oh you might actually be able to
see your family again and everyone else
it's just there's nothing they don't
they don't promise them anything they
don't try to sweet-talk them they just
put bombs in their heads and like send
them into a war zone and expect them to
cooperate and they do because the script
needs them too and scenes that are
supposed to be like moments of levity
okay so there's the there's a scene that
you've probably all seen it's in the
it's in like half the trailers where
Harley like busts open a storefront
window and steals a purse there is
actually less footage of that scene in
the finished cut than there is in the
trailers it goes by so fast
like that is essentially the entirety of
it I don't remember what leads into it
but it's like some completely different
scene with different characters
different place different time and then
that scene ends cut Harley like there
there's like three-quarters of a second
kind of breathing space after the cut
and then Harley smashes the window
there's the entire exchange and the
moment she's like we're the bad guys
who
CNN's like cut it's it's so abrupt
there is no breathing room given to it
at all and and there's a lot of stuff
like that like it's just just kind of
moments that have just kind of been
inserted and there's no lead-in there's
no lead out
there's a point in the climax again the
climax is so horribly edited where
enchantress is like trying to kind of
woo everyone with it's like oh you know
visions of promises of power or just you
know a perfect life or whatever and you
know yeah
conceptually that works but the blocking
of it ends up being that dîablø kind of
breaks himself out of it and then stands
in front of a boring military dude
Deadshot and Harley and so the blocking
is basically 1/3 and it's just this
revert like you know back and forth as
he stands there just being like no you
got to break out of it it's not real
she's playing with USA because he's
super stereotypical and end of the
reverse like no joke is Will Smith is
the three of them just kind of standing
there like Saturday Night Live level
pretend that you've been insourcing
they're just like oh I don't know what
you're talk yeah I'm married I'm married
mr. J and what are you talking about I
got a perfect life and everything is
okay they're just kind of like staring
at nothing and like wobbling their heads
a little bit like this this is this is
what I do when I'm I'm being being
enchanted and it's if if it was directed
for comedy effect it does not play at
all
so the Edit is just awful
just just awful awful and and that's
that's a glimpse into what to expect if
you go see Suicide Squad it's clearly
meant to be a very grim movie uh that
has had comedy haphazardly painted over
top of it and was very obviously like an
hour longer than it actually is and has
they have tried to compress it into a a
quick-moving punchy action film but it's
not it's oh my god